when we look at yesterday's again we
look at a bunch of different shapes but
we wanted to find one thing for all of
the shapes or was it yeah the shape to a
particular looking at they were all
prison do you remember that yeah now for
prisons we said you've got a
cross-section is always the same but not
only is it always the same they're
always going to be like when rectangles
or triangles your organ a weather or the
Sun appeared when all the shapes train
edges like kind of a polygon so today
we're quick that definition didn't work
okay
but today we get a little bit of shape
which still has consistent cross-section
but look at it does not have a polygon
as confidential the shape we're going to
look at is it's old enough now you
should draw one of these as soon as is a
very simple shape and you can see just
like before if I slice it across ways
here every time you're going to get the
same cross-section namely a so happy to
see you seal the end now if I want to
work out the surface area you see that
wraps all the way around so basically
that's well how much paper did I use to
make distances that make sense okay so I
want you to see for a second draw are
still enough for yourself make sure to
speak inside while you do that I'm going
to make some space on the board I want
you to think about how you would do that
how would you work out how much paper
my hiding spot
okay so hopefully drawn a on we can do
it filled up we'll stop there stairs
mine would someone like to offer a
suggestion how can I work out the
surface area right in the air okay so I
got the top and the bottom and we know
the area of a circle each one of those
is going to be PI R squared we've done
that before
okay so possibly Eric circles you got
two of them okay now someone else can
someone else pick up and tell me what
then do we need to add on to that to get
the whole thing yes sir okay so I'm I've
got this idea
right that is culture obviously very
important but taller this thing in the
theaters there will be so this height
matters to me if I take that pan R
squared and I multiply by high I'll get
something employment but it won't be
surface area but something up they won't
know what we will get yeah I'm going to
get volume okay now we'll work out we'll
look at bowling later on so volume is
important at the moment I want to find
something else so can someone else give
me another idea Leo incapable if I want
this area well sure I do
okay so okay put your hands there for a
second this will be a lot easier if we
could actually just work out what is
happening with this thing okay now we've
dealt with the UM the top and bottom
okay so I'm going to get rid of them so
don't feel too pressure that this it's a
pretty ugly looking cylinder anyway now
once you take off your top
c'mon get ready to catch once you take
off your top then you take off your
bottom what you see for a second as I'm
doing this and as you're doing it in
your mind what get left behind and not
just like how big is it but specifically
what kind of things get left behind okay
get ready to catch look okay there's my
shoes lots of PI R squared so then I got
this guy and what is this ah
so before I made it into the curvy part
of the cylinder before I did that it was
just a rectangle very simple shape okay
now what I'd like you to have just like
I've got on my board but kind of rent
paper on the side view what I'd like you
to draw just like I do is an S on the
cylinder that'd be awkward because the
curve think have done it have like nice
neat edges let's be together however and
cook this guy here
she is our net remember what a net is
that surface on the outside can unfold
everything so certain ones circle - I
think you've got this rectangle how do
you find the dimension rather than area
I'm a brick came right private sciences
yes it has avoided no it helpful to
think and how wife now I already know
how to hold it let's I rich and
therefore that's the height right well
this week become she are do you remember
it used to be a thing right you remember
that
that's what used to be and then I
unfolded it okay so when you look at it
like this what's that in relation to my
shape that's the circumference what what
record so what you need to do in
addition to your height what you need is
around this is what's the conference
again I want it to I are now if you like
me you find these two formulas which
both us to do circles and both have
exactly the same letters and numbers you
find them easy to confuse okay now how
can you they want to give me any tips
how can I remember at this one it's area
and this was the conference rather than
other way around any suggestions square
a square what square you took out a
basement ah okay so nothing there a
square like what this is for gays area
right it's not give me an example
what kind of units are used to measure
area how do you we just did in marriage
right centimeter square meters where
from the square okay they're all things
being squared as opposed to a
circumference if the conference is not
something squared if you had say mean
square for your area what would you do
is to comfort them that is right so why
don't you pay attention to is the
dimension of what you're doing right a
circumference 11 one dimensional
quantities your cell line just going
around so you get one mentioned here and
area up here is two-dimensional which by
the way just for a second put your pens
down two minutes
last exercise we will kiss the surface
area and you have to do cross-sections
over and over again every time you are
doing a formula for the area of aspect
right lost a lot of time triangles
rectangles trapezium
I want you to think about this right
triangle 1/2 base height but the area
square this works whatever f v squared
arab rectangle length time read even the
area of a trapezium do you know how to
look at every single one in forms it you
can think of more like what the kinda
something like that do you know every
single one you always multiply two legs
together
did you notice that every single climb
just like here just is time is off by it
time okay you got a two dimensional
quantity you're going to be multiplying
two numbers if you had green up like so
is justly before are and then are and
then h again that's freedom so that
gives you volume because volume is about
three dimension not just read it okay to
player all the way around is h pi so
you've already worked out the area of
each of your circles what's the area of
the curve parts of rectangle yeah
that has it there is the width and there
is light therefore I do put it in the
gap therefore total surface area equals
to PI R square plus dou PI H is actually
nice and neat and memorable it's hard to
get wrong because it's so close to
itself right does it serve zero is still
enough okay now I will point out this is
for a closed window where you've got at
top and the bottom sometimes you have a
look at the questions that you're going
to encounter shortly you'll have them
where they ask you to take the top up or
they just want the curvy part don't even
have a top to the bottom it might be
like a young like a toilet roll okay so
it has ends not closed it's open okay
so pay attention to what kind of shape
you've got how it's related to a
cylinder and then take the bits and
pitch it for easy even with a cop right
so the cops guys bottom but it doesn't
have a top because I'm like one very
useful as a cop right so what's the
surface area on on the outside it's
going to be PI R squared PI to PI H that
it if it was the toilet roll right you
don't have a top or a bottom you've just
got the kept rotating part so it's just
going to be to play our H deserve exit
so you just take the bits and pieces
that you need depend on what kind of
shape you house